have you heard of walk fishing
no i don't think i have you are going to
love this
the new york post uh sums it up as the
woke fish dating trend
shady men are pretending to be
progressive on apps
in an effort to bed progressive girls
according to writer serena smith woke
fishermen are masquerading as
progressive
in order to get laid similar to the
phenomenon of catfishing where there is
uh people post fake dating profile
photos um and there's a quote here from
reddit
of a particular successful walk
fisherman
who said it worked i went to an
anti-trump rally
started screaming [ __ ] trump and a bunch
of people joined in
i kept doing it all night until some
girl some cute girl entered our group
and then we hooked up later that night
he is um this is what i call cattle
fishing of course
i think this is different i think that
this is doing it
from a much more trolly sort of
i think he's purposefully doing it to
say right this is just a tool that i can
use as opposed to someone who genuinely
believes it
i think the no no no but i always said
the cuttlefish didn't believe it
do you not think i think that some of
the guys are so self-deceptive that they
genuinely believe that that's what
they're doing
it's just their method of getting
themselves in they're one of my now one
of my one of my favorite conversations
that i've had
regularly in the year since manners of
crowds came out was with
young heterosexual men who i described
the cuttlefish maneuver to and they
burst out laughing
because that was their dating strategy
because it's the laughter of
self-recognition um it's happened so
many times in the last year
and um i
do think it's cynical uh i think woke
fishing is obviously
just an extension of this i like it i
like this idea the woke
fisherman with his gnarled hands
from his beard and one of those little
hats on top
smoking a pipe at the woke sea
um but well these people deserve each
other
um and of course it's all the
consequence
again of us not having the conversations
we should have been able to have
um if we if we had reasonable
conversations about men and women
and relations between the sexes instead
of allowing the craziest and most
deranged and unhappy people to dictate
all of the weather
then you wouldn't be able to have the
situation where
one person knowing they're being a liar
attracts another person who they have
contempt for
i mean which seems to me to be a
sub-optimal start to a relationship
perhaps
um also if the difference between you
sleeping with someone and not sleeping
with someone is whether or not they
shout [ __ ] trump
i think yes i think that there's
something amiss here
with you know the knobs and the the
dials need to be adjusted
there's a there's a more than a little
bit that's wrong with that
[Laughter]
i don't think you should just restrict
yourself to one thing being wrong with
that
um there's an awful lot of oddities in
this by the way
but in general in recent years the sort
of the
politicization of dating is something
that's very very interesting
and what i'm always interested in that
is the way in which it's one directional
um as far as i know
on gay and straight dating apps
you don't find people saying
no democrats
or um no no
eu
it's only ever the other way around so
there's no running no brexiteers no
trumpies there's a running joke in the
dating scene
um any guy who puts moderate on hinge is
a republican
and the um sense here
is that the overton window of optimal
political um preference on dating has
been shifted so far left
that moderate is now nazi